عقب الهجوم على الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي بان الرد سيكون على الجبهه
كما ذكرنا وقال ان بلاده واستلمت من
المانيا منظومات دفاع جوي جديده من نوع
اكد ايضا ان هذه الخطوه ستقرب اوكرانيا من
انشاء درع جوي كامل لحمايه ارواح
الاوكرانيين
اليوم هناك اخبار ساره من المانيا اتفقنا
مع اولى على تقديم منظومات باتريوت اضافيه
نحن بحاجه لتلك المنظومه لحمايه شعبنا من
الارهاب الروسي سيقربنا هذا بالتاكيد من
انشاء درع جوي كامل لاوكرانيا تحتاج
اراضينا باكملها الى انظمه دفاع جوي اكثر
مما هي عليه الان نقوم بزياده القدرات
المحدوده لسلاحنا الجوي ومدافعنا المضاده
للطائرات خطوه بخطوه
للمتابعه تنضم الينا من موسكو مراسله
الجزيره رانيا دريديه مرحبا رانيا
التطورات الابرز بناء على تصريحات الجانب
الروسي
لو تحدثنا عن الهجوم سيارات نعم اليوم تم
التاكيد على هجوم هو الثالث في غضون
الايام الثلاث الماضيه
بمسيارات استهدف العاصمه موسكو كانت هناك
مسيرتان تتجهان للعاصمه ولكن تم اسقاطهما
بواسطه انظمه الدفاع الجوي قبل الوصول الى
العاصمه وهذا ما حدث يعني امس وقبل امس
محمد في الاضافه الى ذلك او بالتزاول مع
ذلك ايضا كان هناك هجوم بمسيارات على شبه
جزيره القرم بحسب المعطيات وزاره الدفاع
كانت هناك 11 مسيره حاولت تنفيذ هذه
الهجوم كل هذه المسيرات تم اسقاطها وسقطت
في البحر الاسود قبل وصولها للاهداف دون
ان تلحق اي اضرار ماديه او ان دون ودون ان
تقوم يعني ثقوب باسقاط اي من ضحايا
والجراحه في صفوف المدنيين اذا موضوع
الهجمات بالمسيرات باتا محمد يعني موضوع
روتيني ان صح التعبير روسيا تضع مثل هذه
في خانه الاعمال الارهابيه وبحسب
التصريحات الصادره عن الخارجيه الروسيه
هذا هذا الحراك الاوكراني المتعلق بي يعني
زياده وتيره الهجمات بالمسيرات على
الاراضي الروسيه ياتي على خلفيه الخسائر
والفشل فشل الجانب الاوكراني في هجومه
المضاد ومن جانب اخر كانت روسيا تحدثت
ايضا ان هذا يعني ياتي بمحاوله من كيف
لتبرير الاموال والاسلحه التي تقوم
بالحصول عليها من الغرب بهذه الطريقه تريد
ان تقول للغرب انها تقوم بتحقيق اي من
النجاحات على الرغم من ان كل هذه المسيرات
يتم اسقاطها وهذه المسيرات لا تصل اهدافها
محمد باستثناء عده مرات يعني عندما تم
اسقاط هذه المسيرات سقطت على بعض المباني
في العاصمه موسكو وايضا على المركز
التجاري في موسكو سيتي اضافه الى ذلك كان
هناك تصريحات لافته في وقت سابق من قبل
النائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي الذي الى
ان هذه الهجمات هي يعني تاتي في اطار
الحرب الاعلاميه وهي موجهه بالدرجه الاولى
للداخل
الاوكراني وكانت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه
مارياضه خاربه قد اشارت الى ان مثل هذه
الهجمات لا يمكن ان تؤثر على الراي العام
في المجتمع الروسي على الوضع الداخلي ولا
تثير ايا من القلق في صفوف المواطنين على
الارض في روسيا على الصعيد السياسي فيما
يتعلق في صفقه الحبوب كانت هناك تصريحات
من قبل نائب رئيس النائب رئيس الوزير
الخارجيه الروسي ميخائيل جالوزن الذي جدد
الموقف الروسي بالاشاره لان الروسي لا
يمكن ان تعود لصفقه الحبوب دون تنفيذ
شروطها وهذا ياتي بالتزاول مع حديث في
انقره عن انه عن ان الجانب الاوكراني حصل
على ضمانات شفويه من قبل بعض الدول
الغربيه فيما يتعلق برفع العقوبات عن
الواردات السلعه الزراعيه والاسمده
الروسيه ولكن في هذا الاشار روسيا تريد
التاكيد ان نكون هذه الشفهات او هذه
الضمانات الشفويه لا تعني روسيا على
الاطلاق وروسيا تريد ان ترى خطوات محدده
على الارض اي رفع العقوبات عن سلعها ومن
ثم ستقوم بالنظر بامكانيه العوده للصفقه
الجزيره كنت معنا من موسكو شكرا جزيلا